It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢再喧闹，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐起价仅为每月 35 美元。这真是一个不会持续太久的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。需加收税费和政府规费。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. When you picture someone demonstrating courage, what do you see? A firefighter running into a burning building to save a child? A protester risking her safety to stand up to injustice? Or a middle schooler swallowing his stage fright to try out for a school play? When we think of courage, we often envision dramatic high-stakes moments, but courage comes into play not only in extraordinary situations, but in everyday life.
GoogleFi Wireless 在网络高负荷使用期间不会遭受数据流量降速。当你脑海中浮现出有人展现勇气的画面时，你看到了什么？是消防员冲入着火的建筑去救出一个孩子？是抗议者冒着人身安全危险站出来反抗不公？还是一个中学生克服怯场尝试去参加学校话剧的试镜？当我们想到勇气时，我们往往会联想到充满戏剧性、高风险的时刻，但勇气不仅在非同寻常的情境中发挥作用，也存在于日常生活之中。
Today we're going to talk to a psychologist about what it means to act courageously. What do all courageous actions physical, moral, and psychological have in common? Does courage have to involve overcoming fear? Is courage a personality trait, a state of mind, or behavior anyone can choose in the moment? How do our cultural and social viewpoints shape what we see as courage? And is it possible to practice bravery and become more courageous? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
今天我们将与一位心理学家探讨勇敢行事的真正含义。所有勇敢的行为——无论是身体上的、道德上的还是心理上的——有什么共同点？勇气是否必须涉及克服恐惧？勇气是一种人格特质、一种心态，还是任何人都能在当下做出的一种行为？我们的文化和社会的视角如何塑造了我们对勇气的认知？练习勇敢并变得更加勇敢是否可能？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Cynthia Pury, a professor of psychology at Clemson University. She studies how and why people act courageously and what we think about other people's courage. Her research points to the importance of considering both situational and individual differences to understand how courage works in organizations, in the performing arts, in healthcare, and in interpersonal and civic contexts. She has published dozens of peer-reviewed research articles and book chapters and was co-editor of the APA book, The Psychology of Courage, Modern Research on An Ancient Virtue.
我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是克莱姆森大学心理学教授辛西娅·普里博士。她研究人们如何以及为何表现出勇敢，以及我们如何看待他人的勇气。她的研究指出，考虑到情境差异和个体差异对于理解勇气如何在组织、表演艺术、医疗保健以及人际和公民背景中发挥作用至关重要。她发表了数十篇同行评审的研究文章和书籍章节，并且是美国心理学会书籍《勇气的心理学：古代美德的现代研究》的共同编辑。
Dr. Purdy, thank you for joining me today. Hi, Kim. Thank you so much for asking me to be here today. I'm excited to talk to your listeners about courage and how it might fit in with their lives. All right, well, let's do that. I want to ask you, since you've been studying courage for almost 20 years, how do you define courage and has your view of what constitutes courage changed over the years? The definition of courage is actually still being debated among psychologists. My lab and I define courage as taking a worthwhile risk.
普里博士，非常感谢您今天能来。嗨，金。非常感谢您邀请我今天来到这里。我很兴奋能和您的听众聊聊勇气以及它如何融入他们的生活。好的，那我们就来聊聊这个。我想问您，既然您研究勇气已经快 20 年了，您是如何定义勇气的？多年来，您对构成勇气的要素的看法是否有过改变？心理学家对勇气的定义其实仍在争论中。我和我的实验室将勇气定义为承担有价值的风险。
And this definition has several important parts to it. So first of all, it's taking something. you are actually choosing to do the thing. It is a risk. So there is something that might not go well for you should you choose to do this. And it's for a worthwhile or valuable reason. This definition has evolved for me over the years in two ways. So first off, when I started studying courage about 20 years ago,
而这个定义包含几个重要的部分。首先，这是一个“承担”的过程。你实际上是在选择去做这件事。这是一个风险。因此，如果你选择这样做，可能会有一些对你不利的事情发生。而且这是为了一个值得的或有价值的理由。多年来，这个定义对我的演变主要体现在两个方面。首先，大约 20 年前我开始研究勇气时，
the predominant definition was a definition that comes out of clinical psychology, where courage is not letting fear stop you, which sounds appealing, except it's got a couple of downsides to it. First of all, it resulted in some weirdness in the literature where folks who had gotten awards for bravery, there were some decorated bomb disposal operators, for example, the bomb squad who were active combating the IRA in the 1970s. They were hooked up to machines in the lab, and they looked less fearful than people who were not decorated bomb disposal operators. And so the kind of unsatisfying conclusion is that these people aren't courageous because they don't have as much fear to stand up to. And I thought that just seems backwards.
主流的定义源自临床心理学，即勇气就是不让恐惧阻挡你，听起来很有吸引力，但它有几个缺点。首先，它导致文献中出现了一些奇怪的现象，例如，一些荣获勇敢勋章的人，比如上世纪 70 年代活跃在北爱尔兰问题冲突中打击爱尔兰共和军的炸弹处理专家。当他们在实验室连接上仪器时，他们看起来比那些没有获得勋章的炸弹处理专家表现出更少的恐惧。因此，得出一个不太令人满意的结论是，这些人并不勇敢，因为他们没有那么多需要去对抗的恐惧。我觉得这似乎本末倒置了。
And additionally, when you read things that people say or you talk to people about a time they were courageous, a lot of times they do mention fear. That happens in about 75 percent or so of folks who tell me about a time they acted courageously. But some of those times, the fear that the person's reporting is not necessarily fear of harm to themselves. It's fear of not getting the thing that they're trying to get. So if your child runs into the street, I would presume you're terrified. But you're not terrified for you.
此外，当你阅读人们说的话或与人们交流他们曾经勇敢的经历时，很多时候他们确实会提到恐惧。向我讲述自己勇敢经历的人中，大约有 75% 的人会提到这一点。但在其中一些情况下，当事人报告的恐惧不一定是害怕自身受到伤害。而是害怕无法得到他们想要得到的东西。因此，如果你的孩子冲向马路，我猜你会吓坏。但你不是为自己感到害怕。
You're going to be terrified about what's going to happen to your child. in other cases, people don't even experience the fear. They know it's risky, but they don't even think about the fear because they're busy thinking about the thing they want to accomplish, or even in some cases, because it's just not a thing that's particularly relevant for them as fear. And so it makes sense. The sort of first step I took was to kind of take a look at what happens before the fear. Like, what is it that everything that people are afraid of has in common, but also these other
你会为孩子身上将要发生的事情感到惊恐万分。在其他情况下，人们甚至没有体验到恐惧。他们知道这是有风险的，但他们甚至不会去想恐惧，因为他们正忙着思考他们想要达到的目标，或者在某些情况下，因为恐惧对他们而言并不是一个特别相关的感受。因此这是合乎逻辑的。我采取的所谓第一步，就是去看看恐惧发生之前会发生什么。例如，人们所害怕的一切究竟有什么共同点，以及这些其他的行动是什么？
actions? and that would be risk. And so we know from the psychology of emotion that fear is a natural, typical human response to risk, but it's not the only response. The other big change that I have made in my thinking about fear over the years is the absolute inclusion and necessity of thinking about why the person might be taking this action. So if you imagine, for example, two people who are in the burn unit and they've been hurt badly in a housefire, because it's a thought experiment, we can even specify that they were even equally afraid when they ran into the house fire because they did choose to run in. The first person ran into the house fire to save a baby. The second person ran into the
那就是风险。因此，从情感心理学中我们知道，恐惧是对风险的一种自然、典型的反应，但它并不是唯一的反应。多年来，我对恐惧的看法的另一个重大改变是，绝对纳入并必须思考一个人为什么要采取这种行动。因此，如果你想象一下，例如，两个在烧伤病房的人，他们在火灾中受了重伤，因为这是一个思想实验，我们甚至可以具体说明，他们在冲进火灾现场时感到的恐惧程度是完全一样的，因为他们确实选择冲了进去。第一个人冲进火灾现场是为了救一个婴儿。第二个人冲进
housefire to make a really awesome TikTok video surrounded by flames. We're not going to give that second person an award for bravery. We're probably going to give them a psych consult. That's not what we mean by courage. And in my participant's responses, they've almost always talked about things that are deeply meaningful and important to them. I think the reason why the clinical definition, definition exists is because within a clinical context, why is someone coming in? They're not usually coming in because of risk. They're more likely to be coming in because they feel afraid of something that is irrational to be afraid of. They're also not likely to be told or encouraged or even slightly supported by their therapist in taking what most folks would deem a stupid action. So if I come in
火灾现场是为了拍一个被火焰包围的、非常酷的 TikTok 视频。我们不会给第二个勇敢奖。我们可能会建议他们去看心理医生。这并不是我们所说的勇气。在参与者的回答中，他们几乎总是谈到对他们而言具有深远意义和重要性的事情。我认为之所以存在临床定义，是因为在临床背景下，为什么有人会来求助？他们通常不是因为风险而来。他们更有可能是因为对某种不合理的恐惧感到害怕而前来。他们的治疗师也不太可能会告诉、鼓励或甚至稍微支持他们去做大多数人认为愚蠢的行为。因此，如果我来
for therapy and I say, hey, Doc, I am really stressed and I'm really afraid, I would like to sit in the center lane of traffic, but I can't get myself to do it. You would not be a good therapist if you encourage the person to do that. You would probably lose your license. And so within the context of psychotherapy, that's what courage typically looks like. But in the context of other situations, sort of a whole life situation, it's more general than that. Although I suspect our listeners think they understand what constitutes courage, isn't it the case that we actually disagree quite a bit on this point? For instance, one of the examples I've seen a lot in researching this talk is that some people think undergoing gender transition.
做治疗时我说，嘿，医生，我压力太大了，我真的很害怕，我想坐在车流的正中央，但我就是做不到。如果你鼓励这个人这样做，你就不是一个好治疗师。你可能会吊销执照。因此，在心理治疗的背景下，这通常就是勇气呈现出的样子。但在其他情境中，比如整个人生情境，它的含义要比这更广泛。尽管我猜我们的听众认为他们理解什么是勇气，但难道事实不是我们在这一点上其实存在相当大的分歧吗？例如，我在研究这个话题时经常看到的一个例子是，有些人认为经历性别重置
is a courageous act while other people don't share that view or some people think that, say, harming or killing a doctor who performs abortions is courageous. Are there actions that are objectively courageous? I wouldn't say that they are objectively courageous because I'm not sure I want to use that term. But in our research, we study courage both as a process. So how do people decide to and get themselves to take an action, but also as an accolade. So what is that we call courageous in both others and in ourselves. For someone to call something courageous, they are implicitly saying, I can see how this is a threat for you, and I see this as valuable. And so if we think back to our patients in the hospital, we can add a third and maybe even a
是一个勇敢的行为，而其他人并不认同这种观点，或者有些人认为，伤害或杀害实施堕胎的医生是勇敢的。是否存在客观上勇敢的行为？我不会说它们是客观上勇敢的，因为我不确定我是否想用这个词。但在我们的研究中，我们将勇气既作为一种过程来研究——人们是如何决定并促使自己采取行动的，同时也将其作为一种赞誉来研究——我们在他人和自己身上称为什么是勇敢。当有人称某事为勇敢时，他们含蓄地表达的是：我能看出这对你来说是一个威胁，我视其为有价值的。因此，如果我们回想一下我们在医院的患者，我们可以为在火灾中烧伤的患者增加第三张甚至是第四张
fourth bed for the patients who were burned in the house fire. If third patient ran in to save a pet, The amount of courage you think that person has is likely dependent on how much you value pets and see them as family members versus how much you see them as sort of indoor livestock. You can take it even a step further because I suspect most of your listeners picture pet and you picture your cat, you picture your dog, you picture your bird. But what if you pictured your ant farm? Would it be courageous to run back into the house to save an ant farm? What about running back into the burning house to save your favorite potted plant? You can come up with all sorts of different scenarios here, but when we have actually asked people about the courage of specific publicly occurring events, most notably for one of our studies,
病床。如果第三个患者冲进去是为了救一只宠物，你认为这个人拥有的勇气有多大，很可能取决于你有多大程度上重视宠物并将它们视为家庭成员，还是将它们视为某种室内家畜。你甚至可以更进一步，因为我猜你大部分的听众在脑海中浮现宠物时，想到的是猫、是狗、是鸟。但如果你想到的是你的蚂蚁农场呢？跑回着火的房子去救一个蚂蚁农场算勇敢吗？跑回着火的房子去救你最喜欢的盆栽植物呢？你可以在这里想出各种各样的情景，但是当我们真正询问人们关于特定公开事件的勇气时，最值得注意的是我们的其中一项研究，
Caitlin Jenner, when she first came out as transgender, and Kim Davis, when she first was in the news for not issuing same-gender, marriage licenses. And we got exactly the results that I think we would all expect that people who endorse very traditional heteronormative values say that Kim Davis was courageous and Caitlin Jenner was not. And it flips for people who do not have those, their values are different. Let's shift for a moment and ask about the different types of courage. So what are the differences among physical courage, moral courage, and personal courage, and how are they similar? Let's start with personal courage first. So for me, in my research and research that I've jointly done with Charlie Starkey, who's a philosopher here at Clemson, personal courage happens when
凯特琳·詹娜（Caitlin Jenner）刚公开跨性别身份时，以及金·戴维斯（Kim Davis）因拒绝签发同性结婚证而登上新闻时。我们得到了我想象中所有人都预料到的结果：那些赞同非常传统的异性恋规范价值观的人认为金·戴维斯是勇敢的，而凯特琳·詹娜不是。而对于没有这些价值观、价值观不同的人来说，情况则正好相反。让我们暂时转换一下话题，来探讨不同类型的勇气。那么，身体勇气、道德勇气和个人勇气之间有什么区别，它们的相似之处又在哪里？让我们首先从个人勇气开始。因此对我而言，在我的研究以及我与克莱姆森大学哲学家查理·斯塔基（Charlie Starkey）共同开展的研究中，个人勇气发生在
people do something that is risky for them, but not necessarily risky for others. It might also be, and we don't have as much evidence on this, that they do something that is meaningful for them, but not necessarily others. So for example, someone who traps and kills a spider, even though they're afraid of spiders, that might be courageous for them, but it might not be courageous for others. And so we would call that action high in personal courage. Other kinds of courageous actions are actions for which everyone can see that it's a risk, and quite frankly, everyone can see that it's of enormous value. So I think this is why firefighters are kind of almost at the pinnacle of courage in most places in terms of accolade courage from other folks,
人们做一些对他们自己有风险、但对其他人不一定有风险的事情。这也可能是，虽然我们在这方面的证据较少，即他们做了一些对他们自己有意义、但对其他人不一定有意义的事情。例如，某人捕捉并杀死了一只蜘蛛，尽管他们很害怕蜘蛛，这对他们来说可能是勇敢的，但对其他人来说可能并不算勇敢。因此我们会称这种行为具有高度的个人勇气。其他种类的勇敢行为是所有人都能看出其中存在风险、而且坦率地说所有人都能看出其具有巨大价值的行为。因此我认为这就是为什么消防员在大多数地方的赞誉性勇气中几乎处于金字塔尖，
because we all understand that fire is very dangerous, and we all get that saving people from fire is a good thing. There's not really a pro-fire contingency out there that's saying, oh, no, this is wrong. You should just let the houses burn. For other kinds of courage that are out there in the literature, and by literature, I mean like ancient, ancient literature going back to the ancient Greeks and probably before, there's a split, a natural split between physical courage and moral courage. And then there's a little bit of a later addition of psychological courage and vital courage and business courage and a bunch of different little flavors. Where these seem to come from is that the natural landscape of goals and risks don't pair out randomly.
因为我们都明白火非常危险，我们也都知道从火灾中救人是一件好事。并没有什么支持火灾的派系跳出来说，哦不，这是不对的，你们应该让房子烧毁。对于文献中存在的其他种类的勇气——这里的文献指的是古老、古老的文献，可以追溯到古希腊人甚至更早——存在一种分裂，即身体勇气和道德勇气之间的自然分裂。后来又稍微加入了一些心理勇气、活力勇气和商业勇气以及各种各样的小分支。这些勇气的来源似乎在于，目标和风险的自然版图并不是随机配对的。
If I'm going to save someone from immediate physical danger, I probably need to face that immediate physical danger myself. Most kinds of physical courage that people report are that kind of courage. If I am going to stand up to other people to do the right thing, I am taking a very particular kind of social risk that they're going to ostracize me. And that is moral courage in most cases. There's not a perfect overlap, though, between all cases of courage and these different kinds of courage. So in really extreme examples, they blend in some interesting kind of ways. Civil rights icons faced tons of physical risks and financial risks and social risks in order to stand up for what's right. And so it's not really possible.
如果我要把某人从即时的身体危险中拯救出来，我可能需要自己去面对那个即时的身体危险。人们报告的大多数身体勇气都属于这种勇气。如果我要挺身而出与他人对抗以做正确的事，我正在承担一种非常特殊的社会风险，即他们会把我驱逐出群体。在大多数情况下，这就是道德勇气。然而，所有勇气案例与这些不同类型的勇气之间并不是完全完美重合的。因此，在极端的例子中，它们以某种有趣的方式交融在一起。民权运动的偶像们为了坚持正义，面对了大量的身体风险、财务风险和社会风险。因此这其实并不可能。
Like, it has the risk of physical courage, but yet it's actually moral courage, sort of at its core in terms of what people are trying to achieve. For other instances, we collected data from enlisted army personnel who were undergoing mental health treatment while they were in active duty. And we found that these personnel talked about the goal of wanting to get better, which is often associated with psychological courage. That was their main goal. But they talked a lot about social risks in getting better,
就像它具备身体勇气的风险，但就人们试图实现的目标而言，它的核心其实是道德勇气。在其他实例中，我们收集了正在现役期间接受心理健康治疗的陆军士兵的数据。我们发现这些士兵谈到了想要变好的目标，这通常与心理勇气相关。那是他们的主要目标。但他们谈到了很多在变好过程中面临的社会风险，
in addition to talking about the discomfort that's normally associated with psychological courage and the courage to get treatment. And so that's another case. We call those cases blended courage. Another example of it that may have occurred for your readers could actually be a case where you save someone from physical danger by taking a social risk. If you've ever taken the keys away
除了谈到通常与心理勇气以及寻求治疗的勇气相关的不适感之外。所以这是另一个案例。我们称这些案例为混合勇气。另一个可能发生在你们读者身上的例子，实际上可能是你通过承担社会风险将某人从身体危险中拯救出来的案例。如果你曾经拿走
from a very drunk friend to prevent them from driving and that drunk friend is really mad at you, that would be a good example of blended courage. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Puri about whether it's possible to learn to be more courageous and how to practice courage.
一个喝得酩酊大醉的朋友的钥匙以防止他开车，而那个大醉的朋友对你非常生气，这就是混合勇气的一个很好的例子。我们将进行短暂的休息。当我们回来时，我将与普里博士探讨是否有可能学会变得更加勇敢以及如何践行勇气。
Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts, with the next grill four-burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销活动现在开始，您的夏天从这里启航。是时候举办夏日烧烤了，Next Grill 四火眼燃气烧烤炉特价仅售 199 美元。整个季节尽情招待亲友，Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅仅售 499 美元。今年阵亡将士纪念日，在得宝乐享超低价格保证。售完即止，价格不适用于 5 月 14 日或 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用其他限制条件。详情请参见 HomeDepot.com 上的价格匹配页面。
You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay.
你之前说这个地方离水边只有几步路。我们只是还没找到那几步路在哪里而已。我们省了多少钱？够了。够去迷路了。或者你可以预订希尔顿的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅数步之遥。希尔顿促销活动正在进行中。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿 App 上预订，最高可省 20%，获得您期望的住宿体验。当您想要省钱而不是惊喜时，您在哪里入住至关重要。希尔顿，伴您好梦。
So is courage, in your view, a character or personality trait and are some people just innately more courageous than others, or is it some kind of behavior that anybody can choose in the moment? I think it's sort of a blend of both. I think that our personality traits, our attitudes, and our identities, tell us what's important to us and tell us what we're afraid of. Research in anxiety disorders and in fear in general shows that it's very multifacifacisting. it. So there's a whole bunch of different phobias in the DSM, for example, that your readers may very well be familiar with. It's not the case that people who are afraid of dogs are also necessarily afraid of public speaking, for example. They're different. And that's going to hold true
在你看来，勇气是一种性格或人格特质吗？有些人是否天生就比其他人更有勇气，还是说它是一种任何人都能在当场做出的某种行为？我认为这是两者的一种结合。我认为我们的人格特质、态度和认同感告诉了我们什么对我们重要，告诉了我们我们在害怕什么。对焦虑症和普遍恐惧的研究表明，它是非常多面性的。因此，例如，在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中有一大堆不同的恐惧症，你的读者可能非常熟悉。例如，害怕狗的人并不一定也害怕公开演讲。它们是不同的。这一点同样适用于
in courage as well. So I talk all the time this morning. I gave a lecture to 300,000. I gave a lecture to 320 undergraduates right before I came to my office to talk to you. I like public speaking. It's one of my favorite things. If you asked me to give a talk tomorrow for another 300 people about something, as long as I know something about it, I'd be excited and I wouldn't care and I would not be afraid at all. But I am afraid of heights. And if you asked me to change the light bulb on top of the stage, oh no, I'm not going to do that. I'd have to have a very good reason to get up there and change that light bulb. But someone who's higher in public speaking fear and lower in fear of heights, it may not be a thing at all. And so that's going to be very individualized.
勇气。所以我一直在谈论这个。今天早上，我给 30 万人做了一个演讲。就在我来办公室和你交谈之前，我给 320 名本科生做了一个演讲。我喜欢公开演讲。这是我最喜欢的事情之一。如果你明天让我针对其他 300 人就某件事做一个演讲，只要我对它有所了解，我会感到兴奋，我不在乎，也一点都不会害怕。但我恐高。如果你让我去换舞台顶上的灯泡，哦不，我才不会做那个。我必须有一个非常充分的理由才会爬上去换那个灯泡。但是，对于一个公开演讲恐惧程度更高、恐高程度更低的人来说，这可能根本不算什么。所以，这将是非常因人而异的。
The other thing that's individualized is, of course, what you think is worth pursuing for you. And I think this individual difference in the kinds of specific actions and the kinds of specific goals that people have is one of the things that makes humans rich and common. and interesting and infinitely fun to be around. It also means that something that's a very worthwhile risk for me might not be a worthwhile risk for you, either because the risk level is higher or you just don't value the thing as much as I do. So I think that there's personality traits and there's longstanding individual differences that play into what people will do. It also obviously plays into what they think is courageous in others or in themselves if they're
因人而异的另一件事，当然是你认为对你来说什么是值得追求的。我认为人们所拥有的特定行动和特定目标种类的这种个体差异，正是使人类丰富、普遍、有趣且与之相处有着无限乐趣的原因之一。这也意味着，对我来说是一项非常值得冒的风险，对你来说可能并非如此，要么是因为风险水平更高，要么是你根本不像我那样看重这件事。因此，我认为既有人格特质，也有长期的个体差异，它们在人们将要做的事情中发挥着作用。显然，这也体现在他们后来回顾时，
looking at it later on. But it also is the sort of a thing that you do sort of choose in the moment as well. So it's more complex than just it's a trait. It's not a trait. What about people who are willing to lay down their lives for something they believe in? Is that a special kind of courage? And is there a difference, say, between a hero and a martyr? I think it depends on what their motivation is. So someone who's willing to lay down their life for a cause they really believe in, it's really likely that they really believe in that cause. The extent to which other people will find that courageous is going to depend on whether they think that cause is wonderful or in many cases that that cause is terrible. We've done research looking at published reports like manifesto type
认为自己或他人具有勇气的方面。但它也是一种你在当下确实会做出选择的事情。所以它比单纯的“它是一种特质”要复杂。它并非单纯的特质。那么那些愿意为自己的信仰献出生命的人呢？这是一种特殊的勇气吗？英雄和烈士之间有区别吗，比方说？我认为这取决于他们的动机是什么。因此，一个愿意为他们真正相信的事业献出生命的人，非常有可能他们是真的相信那个事业。其他人会认为这有多大勇气，将取决于他们是认为那个事业很棒，还是在许多情况下认为那个事业很糟糕。我们做过研究，查阅过宣言类等已发表的报告，
things and folks who have done some genuinely terrible things talk about the genuinely terrible things that they want to do in terms of courage in terms of they know they're taking a risk they know this is very likely to end badly for them they're very committed to doing this what most people reading it would see is a very heinous thing uh silk who is a sociologist has done some some work with terrorists and with the police forces that have been opposing them and find they both talk about their experiences during the Irish troubles the same using that language of courage. It honestly goes back to a quote that I remember from my teenage years from Ronald Reagan that one man's freedom fighter is another's hero. Someone who has a strong desire just to be martyred,
那些犯下真正可怕罪行的人，会用勇气的词汇来谈论他们想要犯下的真正可怕罪行，谈到他们知道自己在冒风险，知道这极有可能以糟糕的结局收场，他们非常致力于这样做，而大多数读者看来这是一件极其十恶不赦的事。呃，作为一名社会学家的丝绸（Silk）曾与恐怖分子以及与他们对抗的警察部队做过一些研究，发现他们在谈论爱尔兰冲突期间的经历时，都使用同样的勇气语言。这老实说可以追溯到我青少年时期从罗纳德·里根那里听到的一句话：一个人眼中的自由斗士，就是另一个人眼中的英雄。对于那些有强烈愿望想要成为烈士的人，
I guess I would also be a little bit concerned that they may have other issues interested in their own self-destruction as well, which is totally outside of the realm of courage. Which kind of leads me to this question that if you do something brave for personal gain, right, which a lot of martyrs do. They think they're going to heaven. Are you therefore less courageous? Does altruism make courage more valuable? Some of the more current research and courage insists that it does need to be altruistic. I've not seen that in my own research, but that's probably because of the way I've been asking the questions. I've been asking the questions in terms of describe a ton you acted courageously. I'm interested in what people think about their own courageous behaviors and how they're describing them. some of the earliest psychological thought on courage came from Herbert Gardner Lord in 1918. He wrote an almost delightful book also called the Psychology of Courage.
我想我也会有点担心他们可能还有其他问题，对他们自己的自我毁灭也感兴趣，这完全超出了勇气的范畴。这差不多引出了我的这样一个问题：如果你为了个人利益而做勇敢的事情，对吧，许多烈士都会这样做。他们认为自己要上天堂。你因此就不那么勇敢了吗？利他主义会让勇气更有价值吗？一些关于勇气的最新研究坚持认为它确实需要是利他主义的。我在我自己的研究中没有看到这一点，但这可能是因为我提问的方式。我是根据“描述你表现得勇敢的一段时光”来提问的。我对外人如何看待他们自己的勇敢行为以及他们如何描述这些行为感兴趣。关于勇气最早的一些心理学思想来自 1918 年的赫伯特·加德纳·洛德（Herbert Gardner Lord）。他写了一本几乎令人愉快的书，也叫做《勇气的心理学》。
We were doing kind of a nod to his book. And he starts off with a definition that's strikingly similar to our own, which is courage happens when the sentiment of fear is overcome by a more. more noble sentiment. That sounds really cool. Sentiment was like early 1900 speak for emotion also. So that sounds really cool. So I started reading this book and I thought, this is great. And then I kept reading it. And then he proceeds in a very prescriptive sort of format to tell you what are noble goals and what are more noble goals and what are more noble goals still. and the book ends with a rousing reassurance that we should not worry about the Great War that is currently raging,
我们当时在某种程度上是在向他的书致敬。他以一个与我们自己的定义惊人相似的定义开篇，即：当恐惧的情绪被一种更高尚的情绪所克服时，勇气就产生了。这听起来真的很酷。在 20 世纪初的语汇中，“情绪”也是指情感。所以这听起来真的很酷。于是我开始读这本书，我想，这太棒了。然后我继续读下去。接着，他以一种非常清规戒律式的格式，告诉你什么是崇高的目标，什么是更崇高的目标，以及什么是更崇高得多的目标，而书的结尾是一剂令人振奋的定心丸，即我们不应该担心目前正在肆虐的第一次世界大战，
because that was around the time of World War I, because Americans and the British are inherently more noble than the Germans. And that's not really a psychological approach. And my own professional stance as a psychologist is that one of the things that differentiates for, us from philosophy, which is a wonderful discipline. I work with tons of philosophers. I love philosophy. But I think one of the things that differentiates us is that we are more interested as a discipline in finding out where people are than in saying you need to conform to how we think the world should be. And if you're one of my philosophy friends listening to this, I still love working with you. Please don't ghost me. And psychology grew out of philosophy. It did. Yeah. So can courage be taught, can someone become more courageous with practice, much like strengthening a muscle
因为那是第一次世界大战前后，因为美国人和英国人天生比德国人更高尚。这其实并不是一种心理学的方法。而我作为一名心理学家的职业立场是，我们（心理学）与哲学（一门美妙的学科，我与成吨的哲学家共事，我热爱哲学）的区别之一在于，作为一个学科，我们更热衷于找出人们处于什么状态，而不是说你需要符合我们认为世界应该成为的样子。如果你是收听这个节目的我的哲学界朋友之一，我依然热爱与你们共事。请别无视我。心理学是从哲学中生长出来的。确实如此。是的。那么，勇气可以被教导吗？一个人能通过练习变得更有勇气吗，就像通过锻炼来增强肌肉一样？
through exercise? I definitely think courage can be taught, and I would love to have more researchers out in the field studying how this can happen. This is a direction that I'm trying to take my own work right now. One of what I think is a potentially very cool area to think about this, is in terms of people's hobbies and leisure time, there's an incredibly cool concept from Robert Stebbins in leisure studies, which is looking at serious leisure, is the kind of leisure where people have developed a strong identity around it. They develop a community about it. There's an ethos in the activity that they love. They have to persevere and get over difficulties in order to be good at the thing that they want to be good at and there's a whole career path. It's like a calling,
我绝对认为勇气是可以被教导的，我很乐意看到更多研究人员在实地研究这是如何发生的。这也是我目前试图将自己的工作引领的方向。我认为这其中一个潜在非常酷的领域，就是从人们的业余爱好和闲暇时间来思考。休闲研究领域的罗伯特·斯特宾斯（Robert Stebbins）有一个极其酷的概念，即严肃休闲（serious leisure），这是指人们围绕其发展出强烈认同感的休闲。他们围绕它建立了一个社群。他们所热爱的活动中有一种精神气质。为了擅长他们想要擅长的东西，他们必须坚持并克服困难，并且有一整条职业发展道路。这就像是一个天职，
except it may not be seen as quite as noble as a calling, for example. But leisure activities are freely chosen. And so these are things that people find important. I genuinely think that a lot of the attempts to try to get people to be more courageous could do well if they were situated within an activity that people find inherently meaningful and valuable so that they'll do it without being paid and many times they'll even pay to do it in some sort of activity that already has a community around it and has specific trainings and so forth. And so there's a lot of different areas that are like this. There's dance, there's music, there's art, visual arts of various sorts. There's writing. In my own free time, I have been performing as a comic improviser and teaching
除了它可能不像天职那样被看作是那么崇高，例如。但休闲活动是自由选择的。因此，这些是人们认为重要的事情。我真心认为，许多试图让人们变得更有勇气的尝试，如果能置于人们认为本来就有意义和有价值的活动中，将会做得很好，这样他们无需报酬就会去做，而且很多时候他们甚至会花钱去参与某种已经围绕着一个社群并具有专门培训等等的活动。因此，有很多像这样的不同领域。有舞蹈、音乐、艺术、各种视觉艺术。有写作。在我自己的空闲时间里，我一直在作为一名喜剧即兴表演者进行表演，并在过去几年里教授
introduction to improv comedy for the past several years. And it is a wonderful place to see people decide that they are going to do this scary thing. Every single class, we have students who say that they're feeling anxious, they're feeling nervous, they're feeling afraid. Many classes, we will have someone walk in and the first day when we go around and like, why are you taking this class, they'll happily and loudly say, my therapist sent me, which I just think is delightful. But there are pinch points. There are places in learning how to make funny things in front of a live audience that make people particularly nervous.
即兴喜剧入门。这是一个绝佳的地方，可以看到人们决定去做这件可怕的事情。在每一堂课上，我们都有学生说他们感到焦虑、感到紧张、感到害怕。在许多课堂上，我们会看到有人走进来，在第一天我们转圈自我介绍、问“你为什么来上这门课”时，他们会高兴而大声地说：“我的心理医生让我来的”，我觉得这太棒了。但这里也有痛点。在学习如何在现场观众面前即兴创作好笑的事情的过程中，有些环节会让人格外紧张。
And you can see the growth arc in them getting over that. And you can also see how helping them reduce their amount of anxiety, reduce the sense of fear. And it's more of the actually reducing that sense of risk rather than reducing fear. It's also reducing the actual risk and pointing it out to them and it's increasing their ability to make the right choices and have a successful outcome and meet that goal, which, by the way, this is a side note, just encourage research in general, people are much more likely to think that they were courageous when whatever it is that they did succeeded than when it failed. In our research, we've had biggest effect I've ever had in 30 years of doing psychological research is looking at the difference between someone describes
你可以看到他们在克服这一关时的成长弧线。你还可以看到如何帮助他们减少焦虑感、减少恐惧感。这其实更多的是减少那种风险感，而不是减少恐惧。这也是在减少实际风险并向他们指出这一点，并且是在增强他们做出正确选择、取得成功结果并达成目标的能力。顺便说一句，这是个题外话，就一般的勇气研究而言，无论他们做了什么，当事情成功时，人们要更有可能认为自己是勇敢的，而不是当事情失败时。在我们的研究中，在从事心理学研究 30 年的历程中，我所见过的最大效应，就是观察某人描述
a time they acted courageously, how much did what you do make the situation better, how much did it make it worse? Biggest difference, the modal response, so the most common response for how much didn't it make it better was 10 out of 10. The modal response for how much did it make it worse was like a one or a two, which is incredibly powerful. We've followed up on that. with a bunch of other studies and the evidence of points that you want it to be successful. But people who are helping you learn whatever serious leisure kind of hobby you want to pursue are typically experts at making sure that they've laddered the steps for you to be successful in my case in improv, in other cases in painting and exhibiting your painting,
自己表现得勇敢的一次经历时，你所做的事情在多大程度上使情况变好了，在多大程度上使情况变糟了？最大的差异，众数反应（也就是最常见的反应），对于“在多大程度上让情况变好了”，是 10 分（满分 10 分）。对于“在多大程度上让情况变糟了”，众数反应大约是 1 分或 2 分，这是极其强有力的。我们通过一系列其他研究跟进了这一点，证据表明你希望它是成功的。但是那些帮助你学习你想要追求的任何严肃休闲类爱好的导师，通常都是专家，他们擅长确保为你搭建好阶梯，让你取得成功——就我而言是在即兴表演中，在其他情况下是在绘画和展出你的画作中，
in writing, in your dance, in your musical performance, in your running, in your whatever activity it is that you're trying to pursue. What got you interested in this field? I mean, why courage out of all the things you could have studied? I started off doing research in anxiety and cognition, and that is an incredibly rich and very, very, very well-studied field. In fact, it's probably a little bit too well studied for my personal taste. There are, I think there's individual differences also in how much people like to be looking at something really new versus really, really, really getting in there and knowing about things. I'm more of the, I like new shiny things. And as I was coming up for tenure, which is this multi, multi-year process in academic institutions where you have to do the right amount.
在写作、舞蹈、音乐表演、跑步中，或者在你试图追求的任何活动中。是什么让你对这个领域感兴趣？我是说，在你能研究的所有事情中，为什么偏偏是勇气？我一开始从事的是焦虑与认知方面的研究，那是一个极其丰富且被研究得非常非常透彻的领域。事实上，就我个人口味而言，它可能有点被过度研究了。我认为，在人们喜欢研究非常崭新的东西，还是真正深入其中并了解事物方面，也存在个体差异。我更倾向于“我喜欢闪闪发光的新事物”这一派。正当我准备晋升终身教职时——这是学术机构中一个长达数年的多阶段过程，你必须完成适量的
of research in order to get tenure. I found that I was just, to use the hobby metaphor, hitting a wall and new studies would pour out of psych info about anxiety and cognition. And I would think to myself, oh, explicative, another thing to read. And it didn't bring me any joy. It was just like, oh, no. There's so much here. And I did just enough to get tenure. And after I did get tenure, I was fortunate enough to be asked to put together a seminar for students, a multidisciplinary
研究才能获得终身教职。我发现自己——用爱好的隐喻来说——撞墙了，关于焦虑和认知的各项新研究会不断从 PsychInfo 数据库中涌现出来。而我会对自己说：“哦，该死（此处用了委婉语或脏话），又有一篇要读的东西。”这并没有带给我任何快乐。它只会让我觉得：“哦，不。这里的东西太多了。”我只做了刚好够获得终身教职的研究。而在我确实获得了终身教职之后，我有幸被邀请为学生组织一个研讨会，这是一个多学科的
kind of seminar about fear and horror. And that was interesting and that was cool. And so I put together a bunch of readings and stuff. And I got to the end of the class and I just thought, this is just grim and depressing. So how can I end us on a positive note? So the first way I thought I could end us on a positive note is if the thing that you're afraid of is irrational for you to be afraid of. Like legitimately you're afraid of something that is not risky or you are vastly overestimating how risky it is. Those are phobias. There's so much research out there on that and there's so many good technologies out there. There's so many good therapies out there to treat irrational fears. So we did a little bit of reading on that. Then we moved on and I thought, okay, well,
关于恐惧和恐怖的研讨会。那很有趣，也很酷。于是我整理了一堆阅读材料之类的东西。当我读到课程快结束时，我只是想：这简直是阴暗而令人沮丧的。那么，我怎样才能以积极的调子结束这门课呢？所以我首先想到可以用积极调子结束的方式是：如果你害怕的东西对你来说是不理性的。比如你合理地害怕某种并不具风险的东西，或者你极大地高估了它的风险。那些就是恐惧症。关于这方面的研究太多了，有那么多优秀的科技。有那么多优秀的疗法来治疗不理性的恐惧。所以我们围绕这个读了一点书。然后我们继续前进，我想，好吧，
what about if the thing that you're afraid of is actually a legitimate risk? Well, you can make the situation safer. So there's a lot of research out there about how we can make our world safer. human factors psychologists are excellent at this. And so we did some human factors reading. And then I thought, well, but what if the thing you're afraid of is a legitimate risk, and by legitimate I'm clearly throwing in my own bias, but it's a risk that you're not likely to be able to modify. And, you know, it's appropriate to be afraid of it because that's pretty dangerous.
如果你害怕的东西实际上是一种合法的风险呢？好吧，你可以让情况变得更安全。所以有很多关于我们如何让世界变得更安全的研究。人为因素心理学家在这方面非常出色。所以我们读了一些关于人为因素的材料。然后我想，嗯，但是如果你害怕的东西是一种合法的风险——这里说的合法显然夹杂着我自己的偏见，但它是你不太可能能够改变的一种风险。而且，你知道，害怕它是恰当的，因为那确实挺危险的。
Well, you could at least respond to it with courage. So I thought, well, I'll do, I'll throw in the basic readings on courage. I printed them all out because that's what we did back in the early 2000s. And they all fit in a small tote bag. There was no other research beyond that. And most of the definitions that were out there were all incredibly standing up to fear-based. And I thought, oh, as an instructor, I'm incredibly sad about this because what will they read? There's not much to read here.
好吧，你至少可以以勇气来应对它。所以我想，好吧，我要加入关于勇气的基本阅读材料。我把它们全部打印出来了，因为这就是我们在 2000 年代初期所做的事情。它们全都装在一个小托特包里。除此之外没有别的研究了。现存的大多数定义都极其“基于恐惧”。我想，哦，作为一名讲师，我对此感到非常难过，因为他们会读到什么？这里实在没有什么可读的。
Oh, no. But as a researcher, I thought, wow, that's super fascinating. So I'm not a particularly courageous person. I sometimes get asked that. I do think I'm I look courageous in some areas of my life where for me, whatever it is is less risky and or more valuable. But in other areas, I'm really not. But I am super, super, super curious. And I thought this was a lovely unexplored sort of an area that could make a real difference in people's lives. Which leads me to one of my favorite wrap-up questions, which is what are the big issues that you still want to find the answers to? Oh, wow. There are so many questions I want to find the answers to. First of all, I would just like more replication of the research that we've done. There's not many researchers out in the field doing research on courage. Secondly, I would like better answers to what courage looks like in a psychotherapy context, because that's where a lot of the research is taking place. And I think that's a very valuable thing and a really neat reframe for folks who go into treatment because they're anxious, that they're actually in treatment just simply being asked to be courageous. And I think that's very cool.
哦，不。但作为一名研究人员，我想，哇，这超级迷人！所以，我并不是一个特别勇敢的人。有时人们会问我这个问题。我的确认为我在我生活中的某些领域看起来很勇敢，在这些领域里，无论那是什么，风险都更小和/或价值更高。但在其他领域，我真的不是。但我超级、超级、超级好奇。我认为这是一个可爱且未被充分探索的领域，可能会对人们的生活产生真正的改变。这引导我走向我最喜欢的一个总结性问题，那就是：哪些仍然是你想要找到答案的重大议题？哦，哇。有太多问题我想找到答案了。首先，我希望对我们已经完成的研究进行更多重复验证。实地开展勇气研究的研究人员并不多。其次，我希望对勇气在心理治疗背景下的表现有更好的解答，因为那是许多研究发生的地方。我认为这是一件非常有价值的事情，对那些因为焦虑而接受治疗的人来说，这是一个非常巧妙的重新构架，即他们实际上在治疗中只是简单地被要求去保持勇敢。我认为这非常酷。
I would like research into how we give awards for bravery and valor and what that looks like for people years down the road. I'd like research into when is it not cool to tell somebody that they're being courageous. So because by saying that someone is courageous, you are saying this is a risk and boy, that was a valuable thing you did. if you can definitely run the risk of making someone feel badly or even making them feel unseen because they're just out there trying to live their life and you're saying you're so courageous, you're such an inspiration. Well, not necessarily. This is just me living my life. It also can be vastly inappropriate. So I said earlier about how courageous actions are successful actions, if you tried to do something and you fail, especially if you fail badly, that feels
我希望研究我们如何颁发勇敢和英勇奖，以及多年后对这些人意味着什么。我还希望研究在什么时候对某人说他们很勇敢是不合适的。因为通过说某人很勇敢，你是在说这是一个风险，天哪，你做了一件很有价值的事。如果你这样做，绝对可能会让人感觉不好，甚至让他们觉得自己被忽视了，因为他们只是在努力过自己的生活，而你却说你太勇敢了，你真是一个激励。嗯，不一定。这只是我过我的生活。这也可能非常不合适。所以我刚才说过，勇敢的行为是成功的行为，如果你试图做一件事却失败了，特别是如果你失败得很惨，那感觉
icky and bad, especially in any of these real high stakes life or death or serious moral issue kinds of things, it feels bad to fail and be reminded of it. So being given a award for this thing that you fail to do but tried is probably not a cool thing or a good thing. Especially, like I said, I would really love to see research that can help leverage people's natural interests and things that they naturally value into ways that they can be more courageous and then ways that they can think about themselves and reframe how they think about themselves and their abilities and their interests to see themselves as having that capacity in other situations when they might need it.
黏糊糊的而且糟糕，尤其是在任何这些真正高风险、生死攸关或严重的道德问题上，失败并被提醒这种失败感觉很糟糕。因此，为了一件你失败了但尝试过的事情而颁奖可能不是一件酷事或好事。特别是，正如我所说，我真的很想看到能够帮助利用人们的自然兴趣以及他们自然重视的事物、从而使他们能够更勇敢的研究，以及他们如何思考自己并重新构架他们对自己、能力和兴趣的看法，以便在他们可能需要它的其他情况下将自己视为具备这种能力。
Will it generalize to everything? I don't necessarily think it would. I do know that I once heard an intro to improv students say right before their showcase. This is the, I've been doing this for six weeks and now I'm going to go and make things up on stage while other people look at me. Experience. Right before that, I heard this one student say something along the lines of, I deliver babies for a living. I remind myself of that, and I know, I can do this. And I thought, well, that's really interesting. That's a bigger leap than I think we make a lot of times. Well, Dr. Purry, I want to thank you for joining me today. It's been really interesting. And I would love to see you doing your improv. Thanks so much, Kim. It was a delight to be here.
它会推广到所有事情吗？我不一定认为会。我确实知道我曾经听到一个即兴表演的学生在他们的展演前说。这就是，我一直在做这个六周，现在我要上台即兴创作，而别人看着我。经验。就在那之前，我听到这个学生说类似于这样的话，我以接生为生。我提醒自己这一点，我知道，我能做到。我想，嗯，这真的很有趣。这比我们很多时候所做的跨越要大得多。好吧，珀里博士，我要感谢你今天加入我的节目。非常有趣。我很想看你做即兴表演。非常感谢，金。很高兴能来到这里。
To learn more about Dr. Purry's and other researchers work on courage, go to the September issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology at www.apa.org backslash monitor. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman.
要了解更多关于珀里博士和其他研究人员关于勇气的工作，请访问美国心理学协会杂志《心理学监视器》（Monitor on Psychology）9月刊，网址为 www.apa.org/monitor。您可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学访谈》的往期节目。如果您喜欢我们所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评论。如果您对未来的节目有评论或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学访谈》由李·韦纳曼制作。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听美国心理学协会的节目。我是金·米尔斯。本集目前没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。